bonjour à tous aujourd'hui public sénat
vous propose une matinée autour de
l'environnement
avec d'abord l'audition de philippe
martin le ministre de l'ecologie a été
auditionné mardi dernier par la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat et la commission du développement
durable
puis on passera à l'audition de jean
jouzel le célèbre climatologue français
a été auditionné cette fois ci c'était
mercredi par la commission du
développement durable sur le cinquième
rapport du giec le groupe d'experts
intergouvernementaux sur le climat mais
tout de suite on revient donc à cette
audition qui a eu lieu mardi
celle de philippe martin le ministre de
l'écologie qui a notamment répondu aux
questions sur le projet de loi de
finances 2014 et qui a expliqué le
fonctionnement de la contribution climat
énergie
messieurs les présidents mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
sans doute parce que j'ai moi-même été
parlementaire pendant un peu plus d'une
dizaine d'années
j'attache et j'attacherai une importance
particulière au travail du parlement et
singulièrement à celui de votre
assemblée
peut-être parce que dans une vie
antérieure il m'est arrivé de servir
dans leur cabinet deux sénateurs tous
les deux issus du même département du
puy de dôme
roger quilliot d'abord puis michel
charasse et que tous les deux m'ont
appris la sagesse et l'importance du
sénat est donc je voulais le dire
d'emblée parce que c'est quelque chose
qui compte pour moi et si hélas roger
quilliot n'est plus là michel charasse
et de temps en temps là pour me le
rappeler je suis hélas pour créer plus
la wii pour certains
je suis je suis heureux d'avoir pour la
première fois en tant que ministre
l'occasion de rencontrer vos deux
commissions et je veux d'ailleurs bien
sûr à mon tour saluer et remercier pour
leur invitation vos deux présidents mon
collègue gersois raymond vall et puis
daniel raoul que je connais
effectivement depuis très longtemps
comme ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
j'ai mission de mettre en oeuvre la
feuille de route comme on confié le
président de la république et le premier
ministre et qui vise à faire de la
france la nation de l'excellence
environnementale
cette feuille de route je veux
l'accomplir avec vous beaucoup parmi
vous connaissent mes convictions
elles sont anciennes et se sont
enracinés dans mon territoire d'élection
le gers hier raymond vall parlait de
jean jouzel à l'instant hier avec le
président de la république nous avons
reçu et écouté le président et des
scientifiques du giec et leurs analyses
leurs constats m'ont conforté dans cette
idée que la transition écologique n'est
pas une option mais une obligation
elle n'est pas non plus une punition
mais une chance et même si certains
résultats ne seront visibles qu'à long
terme il est urgent d'agir pour mener ce
combat la france doit porter une vision
positive des transformations nécessaires
changer notre manière de produire
changer notre manière d'aménager le
territoire de nous loger de consommer de
nous déplacer de gouverner ça n'est pas
rien
raison de plus pour que la transition
écologique se fasse avec l'adhésion de
nos concitoyens je pense que c'est une
tâche importante de nos concitoyens et
pour rebondir sur ce qui était dit par
votre président de nos territoires
parce que je n'ai jamais pensé que la
plus belle des lois aurait la moindre
efficacité s'il n'était pas prise par
les territoires appliquez vous lui
souhaitez par les collectivités
territoriales
je suis aussi comme beaucoup d'entre
vous convaincu que la transition
écologique représente une part non
négligeable de la solution aux
difficultés économiques et sociales que
vivent nos concitoyens nous ne sortirons
pas durablement de la crise actuelle
sans cette transformation globale c'est
pourquoi je travaille en étroite
collaboration avec mon collègue arnaud
montebourg ministre du redressement
productif
sur les 34 plan industriel de la
nouvelle france industrielle dont la
moitié je le dis si la moitié concerne
la transition écologique ce soit le
transport du futur le stockage de
l'énergie la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments
pour être acceptée par les français pour
créer cette adhésion indispensable que
j'évoquais à l'instant il est bien sûr
indispensable que ce changement de
modèle soit progressif collectif et
concerté
le président de la république a
d'ailleurs rappelé que la transition
écologique devait être un projet partagé
ce qui rend nécessaire l'avènement d'un
dialogue environnemental qui soit l'égal
du dialogue social et ça n'est pas
toujours le cas aujourd'hui
la première conférence environnementale
en 2012 a mis autour de la table des
représentants des ong des organisations
syndicales des employeurs des
collectivités locales et des
parlementaires
j'insiste sur cette présence des
parlementaires car je voudrais qu'ils
occupent une place plus importante
notamment en amont de l'examen des lois
président valent mais sur richard et
bizet font ainsi partie du conseil
national de la transition écologique que
j'ai installé le 11 septembre dernier
ce dont je me félicite car nous avions
été nombreux en l'entente a regretté que
les parlementaires n'aient pas été
associés lors du grenelle de
l'environnement
en 2012 le gouvernement avait écrit une
feuille de route qui mettait en avant la
transition énergétique la biodiversité
la prévention des risques sanitaires
environnementaux
le financement de la transition et la
fiscalité écologique et la gouvernance
environnementale
un an après les trois quarts des
décisions prises en 2012 ont été mises
en oeuvre ou sont en passe de l'être
selon un calendrier connu d'autres ont
connu du retard et bien évidemment nous
pourrons y revenir
craignant de la république l'a redit
dans son discours d'ouverture de la
deuxième conférence environnementale qui
s'est tenue la semaine dernière notre
pays ne comptera dans le monde qu'à la
condition de réussir sa transition
écologique et énergétique
c'est un enjeu de souveraineté qui
permettra de relancer notre industrie et
de créer des emplois si nous nous
laissions tenté par l'inaction que
certains défendent la facture
énergétique des entreprises bondirait de
100 milliards d'euros en 2050 et on
inamet imagine sans mal les conséquences
d'un tel renchérissement sur leur
compétitivité
sans parler bien sûr de la perte de
pouvoir d'achat des ménages
j'ai souvenir des batailles menées pour
lutter je vois valérie létard contre la
précarité énergétique
dans mon département c'est en 2004 que
ce phénomène avait été clairement
identifié comme un phénomène qui a
tendance à désocialisés encore plus les
familles lorsqu'elles ne peuvent pas se
chauffer comme il le faut et donc la
précarité la lutte contre la précarité
énergétique qui a donné ensuite une loi
est effectivement une priorité priorité
environnementale est une priorité
sociale
au cours du débat national sur la
transition énergétique qui s'est déroulé
de novembre 2012 jusqu'au mois de
juillet 2013
aucun sujet n'a été éludé les travaux
issus de ce débat nourriront le projet
de loi à venir j'en parlerai tout à
l'heure qui sera présentée au printemps
prochain et débattu au parlement d'ici
la fin de l'année 2014
cette loi nous permettra de respecter
les objectifs nationaux fixés par le
chef de l'état diminution de moitié de
notre consommation d'énergie finale à
l'horizon de 2050 réduction de 30 % de
notre consommation d'énergie fossile
d'ici à 2030 réduction de la part de
l'électricité fournie par l'énergie
nucléaire a mené à 50 % de notre
production d'électricité à l'horizon de
2025 et 23 % de notre production
électrique d'origine renouvelable en
sans compter bien sûr le mécanisme
juridique de fermeture de la centrale de
fessenheim qui interviendra avant la fin
de 2016 dans ce cadre général et
conformément là encore aux engagements
pris en 2002
les demandes de permis exclusifs de
recherches d'hydrocarbures liquides ou
gazeux c'est-à-dire de gaz ou l'huile de
schiste ont été rejetées en application
de la loi jacob du 13 juillet 2011 qui
proscrit vous le savez la fracturation
hydraulique sur notre territoire
sont concernés les permis de brignoles
de beaumont-de-lomagne de cahors de
gréoux les bains de lyon annecy
l'extension de montélimar et les permis
de montfalcon et de valence la
fracturation hydraulique je le redis au
cas où il faudrait de redire une fois
encore est et restera interdite sur
notre territoire
dans le même temps avec le premier
ministre et le miz de l'égalité des
territoires et du logement madame duflot
nous avons lancé à arras le plan de
rénovation énergétique de l'habitat
composante essentielle de la transition
énergétique puisque comme vous savez
l'énergie qui coûte la moins chère c'est
celle qu'on n'utilise pas le plan de
rénovation c'est un outil puissant pour
lutter contre la précarité énergétique
c'est un outil puissant contre qui
inclut des aides nouvelles pour que les
travaux d'efficacité énergétique soit
accessible au plus grand nombre
deux tiers des français seront éligibles
aux différentes aides et primes qui ont
été présentées par le premier ministre
il y a quelques jours de cela combiné à
l'abaissement de la tva sur les travaux
de rénovation énergétique je rappelle
que le président de la république a
indiqué que ces travaux de rénovation
thermique seraient assujettis au taux
réduit de 5 %
ce dispositif rendra possible à la fois
les économies d'énergie les gains de
pouvoir d'achat pour les français et les
créations d'emplois durables sur tous
les territoires je suis sûr que vous
avez sur vos territoires respectifs des
artisans qui aujourd'hui souffrent parce
que leurs carnets de commande sont
difficiles à remplir et qui vont par la
stabilité de ce dispositif ses terres
les aides qui sont importés et ce taux
réduit de tva dont on peut dire entre
nous il aura aussi tentants probablement
à réduire la part de travail qui se
faisait en dehors de la légalité et bien
donnera effectivement de nouveaux
chantiers pour nos artisans à travers
tous les territoires dans le même esprit
pour donner davantage de pouvoirs à nos
concitoyens dans la gestion de leur
consommation d'électricité
les compteurs linky remplaceront
progressivement les compteurs
traditionnels dans tous les foyers d'ici
à 2020 cela représente un investissement
total de 4,5 à 5 milliards d'euros et
une partie du nouveau programme
d'investissements d'avenir
il sera consacré je rappelle que le
programme d'investissements d'avenir
annoncé le 9 juillet dernier par le
premier ministre cinquante pour cent de
ces investissements sont des
investissements dédiés à la transition
écologique et énergétique et qui a été
introduit la notion d'éco
conditionnalité pour ses plans je vais
essayer de le dire très très fort pour
que monsieur gallois qui est dans une
pièce à côté puisse entendre que les
projets d'investissements d'avenir
doivent être éco conditionnelle nous
avons également pris des mesures
d'urgence pour relancer le développement
des énergies renouvelables
le cadre législatif de développement de
l'éolien terrestre a été simplifié pour
faire face à la crise du photovoltaïque
qui je le rappelle a causé la
disparition de 14 mille emplois entre
2010 et 2012 avec une gestion pour le
moins erratique de la question du tarif
de rachat avec d'abord un prix
surdimensionné une bulle qui a explosé
puis un moratoire qui aboutit à mettre
notre filière de parterres nous sommes
là mobilisés pour sauver des entreprises
qui se retrouvent dans des difficultés
mais nous avons prévu de développer 1000
mégawatts de projets nouveaux
en 2013 hier hier à cherbourg
le président de la république a
officialisé le lancement d'un appel à
manifestations d'intérêt afin de
consolider les filières des énergies
marines renouvelables et notamment
l'énergie hydrolienne
mais il y à l'ensemble des énergies
marines que nous souhaitons soutenir et
nous le faisons parce que la france a
une chance c'est de disposer de 11
millions de kilomètres carrés pour son
exploitation deuxième champ
d'exploitation mondial avec bien
évidemment nos outre-mer dans le cadre
du plan national biogaz la france s'est
fixé un objectif c'est que le biogaz
doit permettre d'alimenter l'équivalent
de 800 mille foyers en électricité
renouvelable hors chauffage et de
produits
l'équivalent de 555 mille tonnes de
pétrole en chaleur renouvelable
la loi de transition énergétique devra
notamment stabiliser le cadre juridique
applicable aux énergies renouvelables
afin de favoriser leur essor
par ailleurs vous savez que le chef de
l'état a fait de la simplification des
normes une priorité ce ministère est un
ministère qui crée beaucoup de normes
alors il ancre est parce que parfois il
faut transposer des directives
européennes
elles sont nombreuses mais aussi il a
tendance à en créer beaucoup et c'est un
point sur lequel je compte m'impliquer
fortement n'est pas normal qu'une unité
de méthanisation puisse sortir de terre
au bout de six mois en allemagne et
seulement au bout de quatre ans dans
notre pays
les allemands ne sont pas moins soucieux
des questions environnementales qui a
des explications notamment le fait en
allemagne c'est une sorte de sources
notamment le maïs qui vient pour la
méthanisation et nous c'est plusieurs
mais malgré tout je pense qu'on peut
aboutir à des solutions qui soient un
petit peu meilleures et les états
généraux de la modernisation du droit de
l'environnement ont été lancés 16 avril
2013 pour ce qui concerne les
compétences de mon ministère et pierre
moscovici au moment où je vous parle est
en train de présenter à l'assemblée
nationale un projet de loi dès lé
d'habilitation qui comporte des
dispositions visant à simplifier les
activités des entreprises du secteur des
énergies renouvelables
l'idée est de pouvoir expérimenter dans
plusieurs régions la mise en place d'un
certificat de projets qui assurera aux
investisseurs et aux industriels
concernés la visibilité nécessaire d'une
part et d'autre part la mise en place
d'une autorisation unique pour les icpe
en matière d'éolien offshore ou onshore
par exemple nous menons des deux
expérimentations pour le terrestre en
champagne ardenne pour l'offshore en
bretagne d'avoir un permis unique
environnementale là où il y avait trois
autorisations et donc une
démultiplication du temps passé en
procédure
s'agissant de la biodiversité la
dernière grande loi de protection de la
nature date de 1976 je me demande si le
miz environnement les peuples n'était
pas michel d'ornano la préparation d'une
nouvelle loi de biodiversité annoncé par
le président de la
public lors de la première conférence
environnementale est aujourd'hui très
largement engagé
la consultation va commencer sur le
projet de texte qui prévoit notamment je
le rappelle la création d'une agence
française pour la biodiversité au tout
début de l'année 2015
le texte comprendra également des
dispositions sur la protection des
espèces
la création des zones de conservation
halieutiques la reconnaissance de
l'importance des paysages ordinaires et
l'extension de la politique du paysage à
la gestion et à l'aménagement
s'agissant des risques sanitaires
environnementaux l'adoption de plusieurs
textes législatifs a permis notamment
l'interdiction totale du bisphénol a
dans les contenants alimentaires
une stratégie nationale sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens a également
été lancé et une loi a donné enfin
véritable statut juridique aux lanceurs
d'alert loi qui a été votée après que le
comité permanent pour la fiscalité
écologique présidé par christian de
perthuis mais remis son rapport d'étape
le 18 juillet dernier le gouvernement
vous le savez a décidé d'engager enfin
la france sur le chemin de la fiscalité
du 21e siècle
je suis fier de l'introduction dans le
projet de loi de finances pour 2014
d'une composante car mode dans la
fiscalité de l'énergie hendrix
introduction qui poursuit un double
objectif d'une part taxer moins la
production notamment le travail via le
cicr est davantage les émissions de co2
d'autre part transformer progressivement
notre société en une société plus sobre
en carbone
cette assiette carbone sera intégré au
taxe intérieure sur la consommation des
produits énergétiques polluants c'est à
dire sur les carburants gaz fuel charbon
le prix de la tonne carbone sera fixé à
7 euros en 2014 et sera l'année
prochaine compensée par une baisse la
composante des taxes intérieures sur la
commande consommation portant sur le
volume par un effet de jeu intérieur
dans le mécanisme de la taxe
il sera donc neutre pour les ménages
cela permettra la neutralité dans la
mesure
de la mesure pour les français à
l'exception du gaz aujourd'hui
intégralement exonéré vous le savez de
thijs et et sur lequel ne pouvons donc
pas baisser les taxes telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui dès lors nous
travaillons à un ajustement des tarifs
sociaux du gaz pour que les ménages
modestes n'est pas à souffrir de la
moindre augmentation du fait de la
contribution climat énergie
le prix de la tonne de co2 est prévue à
14 euros 50 en 2015
22 euros en 2016 pour mémoire se
rappelle qu'en suède
elle est aujourd'hui 200 euros et qu'ils
n'ont introduit dès 1990 et que
l'économiste le d'oise et prospère une
partie du rendement de ce verdissement
de la fiscalité estimé à 4 milliards
d'euros en 2016 financera le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi d'ambès sur
laquelle le coût du travail le reste
permettra de financer la transition
écologique
si nous voulons que la transition
écologique se fasse avec les français
n'ont pas sans eux ou pire contre eux
nous devons promouvoir une fiscalité
écologique qui ne s'apparente pas des
impôts en plus mais à des impôts à la
place nous devons porter une
transformation de notre fiscalité par
une fiscalité additionnelle dans le
cadre de la stabilisation des
prélèvements obligatoires
voulue par le gouvernement mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sénatrice la
deuxième conférence environnementale
ouverte par le président de la
république et conclu par le premier
ministre a permis d'inscrire notre
méthode celle de la concertation et des
actes dans la durée elle a aussi permis
de compléter la feuille de route du
gouvernement sur cinq nouveaux thèmes
l'économie circulaire l'emploi et
l'atrazine et la transition écologique
la politique de l'eau la biodiversité
marine et l'éducation à l'environnement
et au développement durable
cette deuxième feuille de route pour la
transition écologique a été publié et
traduit les engagements que prend le
gouvernement à l'issue de cette
conférence c'est et cinq thèmes nous
avons ouvert un cycle de discussions
avec les organisations non
gouvernementales pour valider cette
feuille de route et voir quels sont les
aménagements pratiques que nous pouvons
y apporter pour qu'elles traduisent ce
qui s'est passé le week-end dernier
permettez moi de citer quelques-uns 2
ses engagements pour la première fois un
gouvernement dans son ensemble porte le
sujet de l'économie circulaire engageant
résolument notre économie vers un
système plus économe en ressources et
qui tourne le dos à l'économie linéaire
telle que nous la vivons depuis des
décennies je veux remercier le président
raymond vall pour son implication dans
les travaux de cette table ronde
les discussions se sont appuyés sur les
travaux parlementaires du groupe d'étude
sur la gestion des déchets dont la
sénatrice evelyne didier ainsi que sur
ceux du conseil national des déchets
président et je les croisais en arrivant
par mon ami le sénateur gérard miquel
dont je connais l'engagement sur ce
sujet d'avenir et qui présidera dans
quelques jours les assises des déchets
grâce au débat et à l'implication des
parlementaires présents des engagements
forts ont été pris notamment sur la
durée de vie des produits
la lutte contre ce que l'on appelle
l'aube solans l'obsolescence programmée
l'éco conception et la gestion des
ressources nationales l'emploi qui est
la priorité absolue du gouvernement a
aussi été un sujet central pour la
conférence il est un sujet central de la
transition écologique énergétique et je
salue l'engagement de votre collègue
laurence rossignol
dans ce domaine avec la transition
écologique et énergétique ce sont en
effet des centaines de milliers
d'emplois qui sont en jeu pour les
années à venir
il faut saisir la france doit saisir
toutes les opportunités liées à la
création de nouvelles filières
économiques mais aussi anticiper sur la
nécessaire évolution de certains métiers
l'objectif est de mobiliser les
politiques d'emploi de formation
initiale et continue tout au long de la
vie emplois d'avenir c'est d'ailleurs
ainsi que 2000 éco conseillers basés sur
les emplois d'avenir viendront aider les
familles à faire leur choix en matière
énergétique formation prioritaire pour
l'emploi politique contractuelle contrat
de génération
tout cela pour l'adaptation de
l'économie à la transition écologique
les discussions sur l'eau auquel les
sénateurs marie noëlle lienemann ronan
dantec et henri tandonnet en participer
activement ont permis l'adoption de
mesures fortes
je vous confirme que 1000 captages
prioritaires bénéficieront d'un plan
d'action visant à les protéger
un nouveau plan national pour les zones
humides sera élaboré la solidarité avec
l'outre-mer sera réaffirmée et un plan
ries annuelle de soutien aux
départements d'outre-mer pour l'accès à
l'eau et à l'assainissement de qualité
sera mis en place
concernant la biodiversité marine la
france est dépositaire en mer d'une
richesse exceptionnelle dont la valeur
patrimoniale et économique justifie
aujourd'hui une action renforcer la
connaissance des écosystèmes marins et
littoraux en particulier dans nos autres
maires sera renforcée afin de permettre
leur protection
un tiers des mangroves des outre mer
sera placé sous la protection du
conservatoire du littoral d'ici trois
ans la france participera activement aux
discussions communautaires pour mieux
connaître et encadré la pêche en eau
profonde
elle soutiendra l'engagement rapide de
négociations pour un accord multilatéral
qui créera un outil juridique de
protection des aires marines en haute
mer enfin l'éducation à l'environnement
et au développement durable sera
généralisé pour tous et tout au long de
la vie c'est-à-dire pas simplement dans
le site de l'éducation nationale mais
aussi dans l'entreprise
elle sera intégrée dans les programmes
scolaires et d'ici la fin de la
législature dix mille projets d'écoles
et d'établissements scolaires mettant en
oeuvre des démarches globales pour
l'environnement et le développement
durable seront développées même si des
adaptations peuvent encore en améliorer
l'efficacité
je tiens à la méthode établie dans le
cadre de la conférence environnementales
et du conseil national de la transition
écologique c'est-à-dire celle d'une
concertation large
je tiens aussi à ce que viennent ensuite
le temps des décisions est de l'action
dans cet esprit vous vous serez associé
en amont et vous associé en amont à
l'élaboration des lois que vous aurez a
examiné puis voté ma part est
fondamentale je veux renforcer cette
participation dans la production
législative à venir qui structurent à la
transition écologique et je ferai à vos
présidents des propositions pour que ce
travail et lieu je pense bien sûr au
futur projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique mais aussi à la rénovation
notre code minier et à la loi sur la
biodiversité la réforme du code minier
est un projet attendu
elle sera à elle seule une bonne
illustration de ce qu'il est possible de
faire lorsqu'on veut à la fois innové en
matière de procédure et raccourcir les
délais tout en eux
cédant rien sur la production de
l'environnement rapprocher la
réglementation environnementale et la
réglementation minière et vous observez
l'objet de cette réforme
tous les industriels sont soumis à des
exigences fortes en matière
d'environnement et d'information du
public
mais rien ne justifiait de conserver en
l'état un code minier datant de 1806 un
groupe animé par le conseiller d'état
thierry tuot que vous avez peut-être
reçu déjà recevrait a réuni l'ensemble
des partenaires concernés et à rédiger
une nouvelle version du code minier qui
sera déposé au parlement avant la fin de
cette année permettez moi pour conclure
mon propos de dire un mot de l'état de
notre planète
à l'échelle de l'europe et du monde la
transition écologique est indissociable
par essence de notre action européenne
et internationale
l'europe devra être à la pointe des
négociations sur le climat pour parvenir
à un accord contraignant et universel en
2015 avec une responsabilité
particulière pour notre pays puisque
vous le savez nous accueillerons la
conférence des parties à la fin de
l'année 2015 à paris nous avons tous
suivi les éditions précédentes de ses
sommets internationaux et je vois dans
cette assemblée
certains qui ont même participé nous
avons chaque fois nourrit beaucoup
d'espoir et nous avons souvent connu
beaucoup de déception la france devra se
montrer exemplaire car s'il y a encore
deux conférences du climat qui doivent
intervenir à varsovie au mois de
novembre de cette année et à lima à l'an
prochain il est clair que le rendez vous
de paris est attendue particulièrement
et cette exemplarité
nous voulons aussi qu'elle soit celle de
l'union européenne
nous soutenons d'ailleurs l'adoption par
l'union européenne d'objectifs ambitieux
de réduction de 40% nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre en 2030 par rapport à
1990 et de 60% d'ici à 2040 ce n'est pas
une lubie mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices vous avez sans
doute eu connaissance et vous en aurez
encore plus demain
les conclusions du premier volume du
cinquième rapport du giec présenté à
stockholm vendredi dernier sans surprise
il confirme la réalité dramatique du
changement climatique du dérèglement
climatique
la première décennie du 21e
c'est elle qui va de 2001 à 2010 a été
plus chaude la plus chaude depuis 1850
l'augmentation de la température moyenne
à la surface du globe et l'élévation du
niveau des océans et l'accélération de
la fonte des glaciers sont confirmés
comme des faits scientifiques
incontestables comme et confirmé
l'écrasante responsabilité de l'activité
humaine dans ces bouleversements plus
que jamais l'homme est à la fois le
problème et la solution de cette
question la france a donc la
responsabilité de tout faire pour
construire un pacte mondial sur le
climat en 2015 qui engagera toutes les
parties prenantes sur une limitation des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre afin
de contenir l'évolution des températures
en deçà de 2 degrés centigrades à
l'horizon de la fin de ce siècle
vous le voyez ma feuille de route est
donc bien remplie et je redis une fois
encore que j'aurai besoin de vous pour
la mettre en oeuvre
les conférences environnementale annuels
permettront de vérifier l'avancement de
nos travaux en vue d'une transition
écologique plus que jamais nécessaire et
de ressources et dont je souhaite que la
transformer en opportunité pour tous les
français merci monsieur le ministre
alors
je propose daniel c'est qu'on prenne un
sénateur de chaque commission alternance
parce que sinon on va pas y arriver le
jeu proposerait bien le rapporteur du
budget sur l'énergie à savoir roland
courteau en premier et ensuite donc à
nous aurons chez nous alors qu'un héros
merde pour trouver un nom c'est votre
commission yves rome suivait intervenir
non bon alors finalement hervé maurey
qui a donné la parole d'accord d'accord
alors on va ici d'abord de prendre tous
ceux qui lèvent le doigt
mais d'abord la parole donc entre amis
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre deux
remarques rapide à caractère personnel
et être courtes question en tant que
rapporteur sur la vis budgétaire énergie
la première remarque pour saluer les
impulsions données par la france au plan
européen avec la perspective de la
réalisation d'une communauté de
l'énergie et la défense d'une transition
énergétique concertées aux blancs
européens qui repose sur des
investissements particulièrement
substantielles en matière d'efficacité
énergétique
la deuxième remarque toujours à titre
personnel je considère que l'ouverture à
la concurrence des concessions
hydroélectriques et prématurée au regard
de la répartition de la rente et
hydroélectriques et de la nécessité de
moderniser le parc et ce d'autant que la
réciprocité est loin d'être acquise en
europe mais je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler
mais question tant que rapporteur au
rythme du raccordement de capacité des
énergies renouvelables au cours de ces
dernières années
je doute que nous atteignons les
objectifs de 23 % à l'horizon 2020 nous
étions je le rappelle autour de 13 % en
pardon oui autour de 13% 2012 dont
l'avant gagné que 3 % depuis 2006
je note une baisse des raccordements
notamment de l'éolien et du
photovoltaïque questions sur quels
mécanismes de soutien aux filières
éolienne et photovoltaïque le ministère
travaillait il pour combler ce retard
deuxième question l'article 20 du projet
de loi de finances un store ce qu'on
appelle un verdissement de la fiscalité
sur les produits énergétiques
où en sont les négociations relatives à
la réforme de la fiscalité européenne de
l'énergie présenté il ya deux ans par la
commission européenne avec le même
objectif
par ailleurs je souhaitais vous
interroger sur les conséquences pour les
foyers de l'augmentation des taux de la
taxe intérieure de consommation
proportionnée aux contenus de co2 qui
touchera notamment le gaz dès 2014 mais
vous avez déjà répondu à cette
préoccupation en évoquant des mesures
sur les tarifs sociaux j'indiquerai
simplement que ces mesures là devront
être particulièrement importante et
enfin pouvez vous nous en dire plus sur
l'article 56 du projet de loi de
finances est sûre et sur la réforme du
crédit d'impôt en faveur du
développement durable et l'aménagement
de l'éco prêt à taux zéro dès lors que
l'un des objectifs consiste à rénover
500 mille logements par rénové thermique
majeur longtemps on va pas rendre ton à
la question de monsieur hervé maurey on
comprend moins
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre merci de cette présentation de
votre feuille de route
je reviendrai évidemment pas sur tout ce
que vous avez dit et sur la politique du
gouvernement en la matière j'aimerais
simplement vous poser deux questions la
première sur la contribution climat
énergie on parle de contribution pour ne
pas utiliser le mot impôt qui commence à
être dur à supporter vous avez évoqué la
neutralité fiscale pour 2014 sauf pour
le gaz je ne vous ai pas entendu dire ce
qu'il en était pour les années suivantes
or comme vous l'avez rappelé va y avoir
très vite une montée en puissance
puisque on va passer de 340 millions à 4
milliards en deux ans donc est ce que ça
veut dire qu'en 2016 on aura quatre
milliards de prélèvements
supplémentaires question toujours en
liaison avec cela quelle articulation
avec la mise en place des quotas de co2
pour les industries comment les deux
dispositifs vont s'articuler
et puis deuxième et dernière question
vous avez rappelé l'interdiction qui
était fait à la fracture hydraulique
vous n'avez pas évoquer les autres
aspects concernant le gaz et le pétrole
de schiste et notamment la poursuite de
la de la recherche et plus encore de la
recherche pour savoir si nous disposons
oui ou non de ressources en gaz ou en
pétrole de schiste dans notre pays
alors est-ce qu'il s'agissait d'un oubli
ou est-ce que et nous en nous nous en
réjouirions le gouvernement évalue vers
plus de pragmatisme en la matière merci
donc ensuite
plusieurs doigts se sont levés donc on
chez testons louis est ensuite
donc on est un peu débordé alors michel
teston merci messieurs les présidents
monsieur le ministre je vois que rémois
aussi la question de l'exploration et
l'exploitation des huiles et gaz de
schiste n'est peut-être pas tout à fait
dans le même sens qu hervé maurey et
vous n'en serez pas surpris puisque en
tant que sénateur de l'ardèche
je m'intéresse particulièrement à ces
questions l'ardèche son département la
mobilisation a été extrêmement forte
noël reste extrêmement fortes contre
toute tentative d'exploration et
d'exploitation des huiles et gaz de
schiste dans tout le monde sait que le
conseil constitutionnel va examiner la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité qui a été déposée par
la société texane schuepbach contre la
loi du 13 juillet 2011 qui interdit
l'exploration et l'exploitation des
huiles et gaz de schiste par la
technique de la fracturation hydraulique
la seule technique est aujourd'hui
effectivement connu et d'après ce que
l'on sait de l'argumentation de cette
société elle considère que le vote de la
loi qui a entraîné l'annulation des
permis qui lui avaient été accordés
notamment celui de villeneuve de berg
ardèche constitue une application selon
elle trop rigoureuse du principe de
précaution alors j'espère vivement que
la loi ne sera pas censuré
toutefois si elle l'était le
gouvernement déposera t-il rapidement un
projet de loi pour interdire la
fracturation hydraulique ou bien on
souhaite t-il que des parlementaires qui
ont déjà oeuvré en la matière il y en a
ici j'en connais rédiger une proposition
de loi
alors bruno retailleau
mais monsieur me disent vous avez parlé
à la fois du giec et de simplification
et je voudrais vous donner un exemple
très très concret effectivement le
niveau des océans est en train de
s'élever s'il ya des hypothèses mais on
sait déjà nous qui habitons notamment
sur la façade atlantique que au siècle
dernier les océans ont augmenté de 10,9
cm il ya des conséquences très concrètes
et notamment en termes de submersion
marine il a fallu pousser un coup de
gueule avant trois quelques jours avant
le troisième anniversaire de xynthia
parce que tous nos efforts étaient
réduits à néant par la complexité
administrative pour pouvoir refaire
consolidé réaménager nos digues
votre prédécesseur a alors comment
dirais-je désigné deux inspecteurs
généraux à droit constant qui ont fait
un rapport pour faire en sorte d'alléger
les procédures de ce rapport
je ne retire qu'une seule idée une seule
idée mais elle est intéressante et elle
consiste à simplifier la procédure dès
lors que on a des digues existantes
jusqu'au niveau xynthia + 0
pour l'instant ça fait des mois et des
mois alors le rapport vous avez été
remis avant l'été
ou est-ce que cela en est nous n'en
pouvons plus les maîtres d'ouvragé sont
mobilisés nous savons que l'augmentation
du niveau de la mer ça signifie des
submersions marines en volume plus
importante et en fréquence beaucoup plus
justement erratique et fréquente les
ingénieurs hollandais ont d'ailleurs
calculé qu'avec un peu plus 10 cm
d'augmentation du niveau de la mer les
événements qui étaient de l'ordre
d'événements sans centenaire centrale
devenait pratiquement d'une fréquence
qui pouvait être décennale donc monsieur
le ministre
voilà il ya un cas très concrets
qui consiste à protéger des populations
l'augmentation du niveau de la mer le
choc de simplification vous avez un
outil il vous suffit de le décider dans
des délais plus rapides
sinon il ya plus de plan digues en
france et notamment sur le littoral
atlantique culinaire
oui monsieur le ministre d'abord je
salue votre engagement personnel à
priori vous allez être en cohérence avec
vos idées alors c'est pour ça que
j'attire votre attention sur la
différence qui peut y avoir entre les
discours excellent et les actes qui le
sont moins
dans les transports dans les transports
qui s'adresse dans les transports en
commun qui s'adresse aux catégories des
plus modestes la population on voit que
le gouvernement a pris la mesure
d'augmenter la tva
alors je veux bien tout ce qu'on voudra
mais si vraiment et un problème c'est
celui là
augmentation de la tva sur les
transports en commun je trouve que c'est
vraiment très dommageable à la fois pour
la transition énergétique à la fois pour
les gaz à effet de serre et à la fois
justement pour les catégories les plus
modestes qui ne peuvent prendre que des
transports en commun donc ma proposition
c'est où ma demande c'est quand est ce
que vous allez revenir à 5% de tva sur
les transports toujours dans les
transports
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour dédier des voix à l'autopartage au
covoiturage que l'on trouve aux états
unis qu'on a du mal à trouver chez nous
ils qui permettrait de favoriser ces
modes de déplacement là et toujours sur
les transports quel v quels dispositifs
de reconnaissance des véhicules propres
pouvez vous m en france pour arriver à
faire en sorte qu'on les reconnaisse la
deuxième question c'est sur les bornes
des véhicules électriques
nous avons une industrie en france qui
est parmi les plus performantes encore à
ce jour dans le monde et récemment la
ville de chicago aux états unis a passé
un appel d'offres international et c'est
une pme française qui a gagné l'appel
d'offres pour des bandes de véhiculer
malheureusement en france malgré un plan
vert malgré l'action d'autres
intervenants
nous avons un retard aujourd'hui auprès
des collectivités locales qui impacte
directement le développement dont deux
de ses véhicules et de l'industrie qui
va avec
troisième et dernière question que
comptez-vous faire quelles mesures
comptez vous prendre pour éviter la
désespérance de nos bergers dans le
mercantour dans les troupeaux sont
décimés par le goût bien si monsieur
robert tropéano oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre ma
question est mon intervention veux jouer
et celle de notre collègue keystone il
s'agit naturellement des gaz de schiste
ma première question c'est je voudrais
savoir quelle option le gouvernement
prendra t-il dans l'éventualité où les
articles 1 et 3 de la loi du 13 juillet
2011 sont jugées anticonstitutionnelles
et enfin dans le languedoc-roussillon
le permis dit des permis des plaines du
languedoc a été délivré à la société
lundin international
cette société ce dernier accordé par
arrêté ministériel le 2 octobre 2009 n'a
toujours pas fait l'objet d'une
annulation le permis de sonder les sous
sols qui a été accordée s'étale sur 2003
5 grammes du kilomètre carré et touche
162,3 commune d'un salon sur les
départements de l'hérault et 52 sur le
département de l'aude
par ailleurs comme vous le savez
monsieur le ministre des problèmes
d'insuffisance de ressources anneaux
dans cette région sont connus des élus
comme des populations et cela est bien
nous pose problème car au-delà de la
fragilité de la ressource annonce le
risque de pollution des nappes
phréatiques est bien réelle aussi ma
question est simple
qu'en est il des produits des permis
exclusifs de recherches d'hydrocarbures
non conventionnels et pourrait t'on
avoir un état des lieux de cette
situation je vous remercie ses
interviews grenard
merci une remarque générale et trois
questions particulières concernant le
développement de l'hydrolien première
main que général vous avez indiqué
monsieur le ministre que la transition
écologique énergétique ne devait être
une obligation et en aucun cas une
punition ça signifie que lorsqu'on veut
je pense faire oeuvre de pédagogie il
est important dès lors qu'on évoque ces
questions de transition énergétique de
mettre en parallèle quasi
systématiquement les questions de
pouvoir d'achat
sans quoi on ne se rend pas entendu et
nous ne serons pas audible notamment de
la part d'une bonne partie de nos
concitoyens sur l'hydrolien vous étiez
avec le président de la république très
récemment sur cherbourg et louis gallois
hier louis gallois qui avaient été
auditionnées voici quelques temps avait
exprimé l'intérêt pour le développement
de l'éolien parce que c'est une énergie
renouvelable
parce que nos côtes heureusement son
objet de courants extrêmement fort et ça
peut nous apporter une énergie
renouvelable extrêmement importante
c'est donc un enjeu énergétique majeur
de la même manière c'est un enjeu
industriel extrêmement important
quatre premières firmes pilote de 5 à 10
machines pourraient être installés dans
des délais relativement raisonnable donc
trois questions quel financement parce
que les financements seront très
importants comment faire vite en évitant
trop de tracasseries administratives
même si nous savons qu'il ya quelques
obligations qu'il nous faut évidemment
respecter mais nous sommes parfois les
champions du monde des tracasseries
administratives
donc quel comment pouvons-nous faire
pour que les délais soient relativement
raisonnable et troisième question ne
pensez vous pas que dans ce domaine de
l'énergie
de l'hydrolien il n'y aurait peut-être
nécessiter de la même manière que nous
l'avons fait pour le développement
l'aviation de faire une filière
industrielle européenne en liaison
france allemagne dans le domaine
également dû l'hydrolien comme nous
l'avons fait pour eads
alors attendez dans l'ordre donc l'âme à
son mari oui monsieur le ministre
bonjour je voudrais intervenir sur deux
remarques de la conférence ce qu'est une
grande revue dernier deux remarques qui
sont pas vraiment des questions une est
une vraie question et l'autre est une
remarque
la première chose c'est la chance de la
biodiversité qui va être créée je suis
évidemment tout à fait favorable à la
création de cette agence
avec un mets très important pourquoi
parce qu'actuellement
j'ai remarqué que certaines personnes
s'expriment au nom de la biodiversité et
ne se rendent pas compte des dommages
collatéraux qu'une certaine que quelque
chose de trop dogmatique en traîne je
vous donne un exemple une conseillère
régionale de région paca je peux vous
citer le nom puisque j'ai hynix natio
l'interview qu'elle a donnée a dit il y
à quelques temps il ya deux trois mois
indique actuellement les éleveurs
devaient à 50% changer d'activité et
qu'il devait être guide de montagne
voire agriculteurs du sauvage je pense
que c'est une incompréhension totale du
métier d'éleveur
mais une incompréhension totale
dangereuse parce que c'est carrément
aller à l'encontre et là je reviens sur
la zone de biodiversité à l'encontre de
la biodiversité pourquoi parce que des
éleveurs contribua biodiversité vous
savez aussi bien que moi que le pack le
barca est un endroit les moutons peuvent
avoir des maladies des des maladies
rivaux des sabots à on connaît tout cela
est actuellement les mesures ont des
dommage collatéral très grave y compris
au niveau par exemple des patous qui
s'attaque aux randonneurs et prive les
randonneurs et les bété tête pour aller
dans la montagne donc danger au niveau
des choix des personnes qui seront
compétentes pour siéger dans cette
commission
c'était un premier problème et je pense
je vous ai posé une question écrite à la
question il répond le plus rapidement
possible parce qu'il ya urgence
je vous ai posé la question mais elle
sera écrite donc vous pouvez me répondre
est-ce que les pas de temps que la
france prenne en compte l'article
le 9e de la conférence de la convention
de berne autorisant les états est
souverain en matière du choix des
espèces protégées
chapitre 3 c'est une question qui me
paraît capital est ce qu'on doit pas le
loup n'est plus actuellement un animal
qu'il faut protéger comme il ya dix ans
au contraire 20 à 30 % de population
supplémentaires tous les ans on en
recense actuellement plus de 420 300
officiellement et voire 400 voilà
c'était ma première masse et une
remarque avec une question importante à
mes yeux
deuxième chose alors qu'il n'a rien à
voir mais je rebondis j'essaie d'être
appelé parce que c'est beaucoup de vent
ce veulent s'exprimer
deuxième chose la conférence de
l'environnement a également prévu et
l'éducation l'environnement
je ne reviendrai pas sur tout le monde a
dit il faut avoir l'adhésion des
populations
alors je m'excuse j'ai une certaine
compétence en la matière je voudrais je
dois en parler une minute je suis enfin
j'étais il ya quelques mois professeur
d'université en charge de la prévention
c'est à dire que pendant vingt ans dans
ma vie j'ai fait des campagnes de
prévention sur le sida sur plein de
choses y compris ces dernières années
sur la prévention pour le tri sélectif
pourquoi parce que c'est également
depuis 12 ans présidente de la
commission communication du sida desk
est un syndicat très important qui
regroupe 12 communes et qui permettait
également de faire des campagnes de
communication
je vais c'est très rapide peut y avoir
au show coiffure chuté dans ce syndicat
nous avons travaillé avec natura 2000
qui est une association et 900 mhz et
habilités par les parrains par par le
gouvernement et dont on fait des
campagnes dans tous les collèges et les
étages primaires et des écoles
maternelles de dunes certes d'un certain
bassin de vie de douze communes les
résultats c'est quoi 14% d'un concours
que nous avons largement diffusée depuis
dix ans tout ça pour finir très
rapidement c'est extrêmement difficile
de changer les comportements et les
attitudes si vous confiez à des agences
de communication qui n'ont pas là la
compétence vous allez allez à l'échec
l'éducation à l'environnement ce n'est
pas simplement donné un savoir aux gens
si leur donner des moyens
pour leur changer leur attitude et je
voulais juste vous mettre en garde
excusez moi monsieur messer pin c'est
une mise en garde ce n'est pas le mot
vous signalez simplement qu'il y à des
laboratoires de recherche qui travaille
là dessus
l'ademe l'a compris l'ademe a donné à
quelques à bord entre de recherche des
compétences et des contrats je pense que
c'est très important de revoir ce
problème si vous voulez que comme vous
l'avez dit dix mille dix mille projets
dans les écoles mais par qui allez vous
passer
c'est l'inspecteur est ce qu'ils sont
prêts c'est les enseignants est ce
qu'ils sont prêts voilà merci monsieur
nice mêlant blues et madame posée
à isoler ça a été difficile de regarder
bien merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous avez évoqué en
parlant des sources énergies
renouvelables la nécessité de relancer
le solaire les énergies marines et et
hydroliennes en particulier la
simplification de la filière éolienne et
on peut en être d'accord vu la situation
de ces filières mais vous n'avez pas
mentionner de sources d'énergie
renouvelables qui me sont chers et qui
sont particulièrement efficiente
selon le rapport de la cour des comptes
qui a été publié en juillet 2013
la biomasse y compris forestière
représente 54 5% de la production de
sources d'énergie renouvelable pour 19,3
pour cent de fonds publics mobilisés
or nous constatons en ce moment une
stagnation des projets de réseaux de
biomasse forestière en particulier et
des difficultés liées au fameux appel de
la creux en matière de cogénération sur
lesquels nous travaillerons demain dans
cette salle j'aimerais savoir quelle
mesure vous prévoyez notamment au niveau
du fonds chaleur dont le montant de 250
millions n'a jamais été n'a jamais
atteint celui qui était prévu du double
est-ce que vous pouvez nous affirmer que
dans le budget 2014 vous parviendrez à
un niveau suffisant pour répondre aux
besoins
la deuxième source d'énergie
renouvelable dont je veux parler c'est
l'hydraulique puisqu'elle représente 30%
de la production de sources d'énergie
renouvelable et elle n'a mobilisé que de
2 8% de fonds publics c'est certainement
lié d'ailleurs à la situation de
d'attentes qui est
lié à la question qu'a posée roland
courteau du renouvellement des
concessions
il se trouve que je représente un
département bordier de la dordogne un
des grands fleuves producteur
d'électricité mais oui monsieur raoul
c'est un fleuve
il suffit de regarder l'embouchure pour
voir que c'est un fleuve qui va jusqu'à
l'océan et donc j'aimerais connaître
votre position concernant la nécessité
de pratiquer au plus vite une
clarification de cette situation parce
qu'il y à des investissements bloqués
notamment des stations des steppes comme
celle de renard et il y à une forte
attente en particulier des collectivités
territoriales pour la redevance qui
pourrait leur être attribuées surtout
pour les départements où la situation
on le sait est difficile enfin moi je me
réjouis de cette contribution énergie
qui vient d'être mise en place
je souhaite ardemment que l'on pense aux
la filière forêt bois qui mérite
vraiment d'être subventionnés en
particulier pour tout ce qui concerne le
reboisement car si l'on sait en ce
moment mobiliser la forêt va toujours
très bien mais en général quand même on
sait faire il faut reboiser pour un
développement durable dans l'avenir
merci dans l'ordre le sénateur bailly
ensuite le sénateur henri tandonnet et
rémy pointereau voyez en dernier
monsieur l'abbé merci président monsieur
le ministre vous avez dit je crois de
reprise qu'il fallait avoir l'adhésion
de nos concitoyens mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il ya quand même un problème par rapport
à bon par rapport aux professions que je
connais peut-être un pimp up mieux que
les autres c'est l'agriculture on vous
le savez n'oubliez pas que c'est quand
même 55 % du territoire
qui est utilisé par les agriculteurs et
je parle encore pas des forestiers pour
aller aux 80% de notre territoire
or aujourd'hui les agriculteurs je crois
que le déplacement du premier ministre à
rennes en était l'exemple
aujourd'hui on sait qu'au niveau de
l'agriculture il ré de réels problèmes
par rapport à des craintes mais pas que
des craintes sur l'augmentation des
chargements et jean vient bien sûr à ce
qui est la taxe carbone et qui va être
un coup supplémentaire sans être sans
savoir si les agriculteurs pour le
répercuter dans leurs prix
vous avez pu voir aussi com - le
président des coopératives de france qui
s'est élevé en 10 ans on va taxer six
fois nos produits qui vont dans nos
fermes ou qui en sortent et qu'on va
taxer qu'une fois et bien les produits
qui arrivent dans nos ports donc déjà
l'utilisation de la taxe carbone
d'ailleurs quand on voit hollande va
annoncer une taxe carbone de 4 milliards
en 2016 vous comprendrez que les
agriculteurs ils sont quand même très
inquiet deuxième chose aussi
les prix de l'eau j'ai ici les
l'augmentation par exemple de la taxe
d'assainissement sur l' agence de l'eau
de corse méditerranée 2 00 38 en 2008 et
les herbes 0,281 c'est plus d'une
multiplication par sept fois et vous
savez que cela aussi coûte
on a pu voir aussi dans la presse que
vous il ya aussi un souhait
d'augmentation les textes sur les
rituels de mogadiscio 10 centimes de
taxe supplémentaire et vous comprendrez
bien que tout ça les agriculteurs dont
tous ces termes là ont quand même
beaucoup aujourd'hui d'interrogation je
parle pas des problèmes de biodiversité
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que je
l'avais lu dans votre conférence sud
presse suite à la conférence
environnementale qu'elle et se mettre en
place la chance française de la
biodiversité
mais déjà sous prétexte de biodiversité
aujourd'hui on peut pas faire beaucoup
de choses alors est-ce qu'on a analysé
le coot de cet agent supplémentaire
parce qu'il me semblait que dans le pays
on devait aussi à moins de créer quelque
chose analyser les coûts
alors vous avez dit aussi monsieur le
ministre si la bresse que finalement la
baisse du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité se doit durant nos
quinquas baroche le mouvement du coût de
l'électricité
pourtant le progrès de lyon me disais
nous disait qu'une tranche de centrale
supplémentaire de 1000 100 mégawatts
ça représente mille huit cent mille huit
cent cinquante éoliennes pour les
remplacer il faut treize mille hectares
de photovoltaïques ou il faut trois cent
soixante mille hectares de forêt alors
quand j'aime entendre collègues sur la
forêt quand on sait le noeud pour
arriver aux 50% que vous avez annoncé
tout à l'heure
et quand je vois que dans mon
département aujourd'hui on n'a encore
pas pu avoir un parc photovoltaïque pas
une éolienne toujours du fait de la
biodiversité parce que toujours on a
trouvé ici ou là soit une faune et une
flore qui les empêchaient à l'oms et de
ministres là je crois que dans sur ses
propos et ceux que vous annoncez je
crois que ce serait là sera pas possible
parce que je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte le nombre d'éoliennes
qu'il faudra créer dans ce pays parce
que je vous ai dit pour pourra justement
qu'une tranche de centrale nucléaire ce
qu'ont bien qu'il fallait sauf si le
programme les journaux dont donner des
mauvaises informations
alors mon intérêt mais j'ai de mes deux
choses résumé mais deux questions par
rapport à l'agriculture comment vous
pensez qu'on pourra prendre en charge
toutes ces charges supplémentaires est
ce que vous pensez que vraiment avec la
transition énergétique
contrairement à vos propos et bien que
l'électricité sera pas dans l'obligation
d'augmenter voilà deux questions
précises y en aurait d'autres me josée
poser une question orale sur d'autres
sujets mais je bien sûr il ya deux ans
ou trois ans elle prévue dans me l'a
rappelé souvent monsieur nous je suis
aujourd'hui j'ai plus besoin de défendre
comme quoi les éleveurs sont trop
beaucoup trop attaqué par les loups
parce que j'ai des collègues qui vient
d'un petit peu maintenant tout l'est de
la france ou de nos montagnes et kim ont
relayé donc j'en suis ravi je suis henri
tandonnet
si bertrand mais chez nous c'est le
ministre moi je voulais vous poser aussi
une question sur la politique de l'eau
vous savez il ya eu de gros travaux
cette année sur la politique publique de
l'eau vous avez produit un rapport en
tant que député il ya eu le rapport de
michel lesage celui de madame legros le
travail du comité national de l'eau vous
avez évoqué les grandes lignes de votre
feuille de route mais je voulais vous
poser une question sur l' agence de
française depuis aux diversités qui
amène de nombreuses réticences
quel est le périmètre de cette agence
que vous envisagez et quel est son
financement
la deuxième question il me paraît
important d'ailleurs au vu des
conclusions plutôt inquiétante du giec
le mettre en place une politique
d'anticipation d'adéquation entre les
besoins en eau besoins urbains
industriels agricoles et des ressources
parce que c'est un travail de longue
haleine et je voudrais savoir quelle
comment vous envisagé de mettre cette
politique en place et enfin une question
plus régionale c'est le savez que votre
prédécesseur avait institué un moratoire
sur la création des réserves de
substitution envisagez-vous de lever
rapidement ce moratoire pour les gens du
sud-ouest ont soif monsieur rémy
pointereau écouter les questions je
voulais poser viennent d'être posés donc
s'agissait la première c'était salder
d'hervé maurey concernant les gaz de
schiste savoir si on allait savoir un
jour ou non ce qu'on a sous les pieds si
on continue la recherche pour ensuite
exploiter si si on a des richesses ou
sous nos pieds la deuxième ça concerne
les ressources en eau ou les adultères
sont de plus en plus soumis à des
restrictions de dos dans les forages et
les nappes alluviales et est-ce qu'on va
un jour oui ou non
faciliter la mise en place de retenues
collinaires ou de substitution
parce que sur le plan administratif
c'est toujours très compliqué et même
parfois impossible à certains
département de mettre en place ces
réserves est vous qui apparemment
connaissait bien le sujet j'aimerais
avoir une réponse ferme et définitive
votre part merci monsieur l'abbé ensuite
on termine par monsieur le noir merci je
vais ça m'étonnerait très rapidement
donc je viens d'entendre mais mon père
on peut avoir des positions
diamétralement opposées j'ai un doute
entendre les problèmes posés par la
biodiversité la biodiversité c'est une
chance c'est une chance que l'on doit
préserver et se donner les moyens de la
préserver donc pour ma part je salue la
halle à l'arrivée la future loi sur la
biodiversité et la création de l'agencé
en question
j'aurai deux points trois points
tout d'abord le plan ecophyto 2018
monsieur le ministre qui pour le moment
est loin d'être d'être sur les sur les
bons rails
quelle position comment rectifier votre
position monsieur le ministre la
position du gouvernement par rapport aux
parcs naturels régionaux je sais que
demain vous vous déplacez aux journées
départ j'y serai également les parcs
naturels
c'est aussi une chance exemplarité
innovation excellence mais je crois que
par les temps qui courent il ya besoin
de signaux forts de soutien du
gouvernement pour c'est pour ces
territoires et enfin vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure de la question du pacte
mondial sur le climat avec avec paris
2015 il ya aussi la question de
l'alimentation l'instant on a tendance à
dire le climat ministre de
l'environnement l'alimentation milices
de l'agriculture évidemment tout est
transversale et sur la question de
l'alimentation au niveau mondial pacte
mondial de l'ale de l'alimentation il ya
la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire des pays du sud
et quelle peut être la position
française par rapport à celle là parce
que parce qu'on pourrait être exemplaire
à l'échelle européenne pour avancer vers
la merci c'est le noir qui a promis une
intervention cours merci jeu permettra
monsieur le cambre de pouvoir intervenir
mais force est en train de décliner ma
voix en train de s'effacer c'est
peut-être la dernière fois que j'aurai
l'occasion de m'exprimer donc fruits
remercie près on va pleurer
monsieur le ministre un sujet là pas
vraiment été abordée c'est le nucléaire
lors de questions
le brillant la république a estimé que
d'ici à 2035
on était en mesure de diminuer de 50 %
la capacité des de production des
centrales électronucléaires un rapport
de l'office parlementaire qui était
signée de bruno sido sénateur et
j'arrive le déaut député démontre que ce
n'est pas possible ça ne pourrait être
que en 2050 est ce que vous avez une
idée là-dessus deuxièmement vous avez
affirmé d'ailleurs assez curieusement
dans un journal du dimanche en juillet
je vais fermer fessenheim en 2016
je passe sur le raccourci je pense que
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça mais
est ce que vous êtes en mesure de nous
préciser le calendrier auquel vous êtes
soumis notamment par les règles édictées
par l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
pour ce qui est de la fermeture je dis
bien la fermeture ait pas de l'art et la
fermeture la centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim
je dis tout de suite je ne crois pas
qu'il soit possible même c'est
impossible de la ferme et encore une
fois fermé d'ici à 2016 enfin en ce qui
concerne un sujet sur lequel nous aurons
l'occasion d'échanger qui s'appelle les
hydrocarbures non conventionnels ou de
roche mère je voudrais vous demander si
vous estimez qu'il ne serait pas normal
d'abroger la circulaire de votre
prédécesseur qu'il 21 septembre 2012
tout simplement interdit l'étude
sismique des sous sols ce qui empêche la
connaissance de vol elle l'a fait
d'ailleurs dit-elle en application de la
loi du 13 juillet 2011 ce qui est à
contre sens car ça l'était absolument
pas évoqué enfin dernière question
monsieur le ministre on rentre je rentre
et des états unis avec mon collègue fait
sans bataille où il est bien de quelle
mission il s'agissait et le matin et le
matin à l'aéroport nous lisons sur la
halle du dimanche et les déclarations
est fait je fermerai fessenheim en 2016
et vous avez parlé également de votre
visite faite en 2010 aux états unis en
2010 ou 2011 bordelais mois aux etats
unis
j'ai vu j'ai lu votre rapport bon vous
étiez contre en allant aux états unis
vous êtes revenus contre vous avez
visité les mêmes sites que nous
rencontrer à peu près les mêmes
personnes que nous mais vous affirmez
dans le journal du dimanche
moi j'ai assisté des fracturations
hydrauliques
c'est violent pour l'environnement c'est
terrible alors je vous voir en chair en
os parce que moi j'ai assisté exactement
aux mêmes événements des fracturations
hydrauliques
je n'ai rien senti j'ai vu simplement
sur les écrans qui se passait des choses
parce que les chiffres changé est ce que
vous pourriez être plus précis parce que
vous êtes allé aussi là bas moi même
j'aurais l'occasion de rapporter sur
cette question sur ce que vous avez
ressenti séisme qui s'est déroulé sous
vos pieds des filles hollande
tremblements auquel vous avez assisté
qui ont su bien vous permettre d'avancer
une telle affirmation sur le camp très
brièvement ministre de questions
la première concerne l'extension des
tarifs sociaux quelles sont les mesures
prises par le gouvernement depuis avril
pour assurer la transmission des
informations par fichier pour permettre
d'assurer plus largement possible a
droit à l'énergie
la seconde question vous m'avez inquiété
tout à l'heure en disant à nouveau plan
pour les zones humides sera élaboré nous
sommes en train de terminer les zonages
sur les territoires si on annonce un
nouveau plan cela veut-il dire qu'il y
aura un durcissement de la
réglementation sur ces zones humides
demain merci on va demander aux milices
de prendre sa respiration parce que il
est victime de son succès là je sais pas
si je pourrai répondre à toutes les
questions mais je m'engage
d'ores et déjà à ce que puisque mes
collaborateurs les ont tous et toutes
noté qu'il puisse y être répondu si
jamais jean jean d'oublier je vais je
vais tout de suite répondre par ce qui
peut paraître du détail ou anecdotique
mais qui concerne les loups dont
plusieurs d'entre vous ont parlé
il se trouve que depuis trois semaines
maintenant je suis en contact régulier
téléphonique chaque semaine avec le
président de la fédération ovine du
mercantour et qui n'avait jamais eu une
ministre au téléphone d'ailleurs avant
moi jamais et qui m'a dit que j'étais le
ministre qui tenait parole à la
différence de tous ceux qui l'avaient
précédé y compris mme expliquait-il ceux
du quinquennat précédent
en effet comme vous le savez le loup
dont ce matin nous avons encore appris
que 75% des français soutenaient sa
présence et sa protection dans nos
territoires pour une grande partie
d'urbain qui n'auront jamais à être
confrontés à la réalité d'un face à face
avec un loup mais c'est comme ça vous
savez ce qu'on dit l'homme est un loup
pour l'homme
donc nous sommes obligés de tenir compte
de cela il n'empêche que le loup est une
espèce protégée que nous avons une
commission européenne qui surveille ce
que nous faisons pour autant nous avons
établi un plan loup qui a été accepté et
compris par les associations qui
défendent et qui protège le loup et ce
plan loup prévoyait la possibilité de
prélèvement de 24
loup dans les deux ans qui viennent pour
faire en sorte que les attaques très
violentes qui sont subies dans certains
départements notamment dans trois
départements de la région provence alpes
côte d'azur ne nous conduisent pas un
jour de voir réintroduire la brebis dans
le mercantour
faute d'avoir tenu le plan que nous
avions engagé et j'ai donné des
instructions j'ai donné des instructions
notamment pour que en étant encadrés par
les agents de mon ministère qui sont là
pour ça il puisse y avoir débattu de
grand gibier qui ont associé les
chasseurs je lis bien dans ces trois
départements là et pas dans les autres
parce que semblerait que le préfet de la
drôme et pu considérer qu'ils étaient
aussi concernées alors qu'il ne l'est
pas je le redis ici solennellement mais
nous avons obtenu cinq prélèvements cinq
prélèvements depuis trois semaines ce
qui veut dire que le plan loup avec
effectivement des loups qui devenait
très destructeur non seulement les brody
me mêler pas tous ces derniers de ces
chiens énormes qui sont là pour la
protection et bien nous sommes parvenus
à ce que je veux vous dire aux uns et
aux autres qui sont intervenus c'est que
dans cette affaire je ne fais preuve pas
du tout d'angélisme
plusieurs ont parlé d'agriculture pardon
de le dire mais je suis l'élu au départ
d'un département qui est probablement un
des plus rurales et je suis baigné dans
l'agriculture je crois bien connaître ne
suis pas un écologiste hors sol je sais
ce que ce qu'est la réalité de nos
agriculteurs
mais pour autant pour autant je souhaite
que ce soit le plan loup qui soient
appliquées dans les années qui viennent
je vais continuer de le suivre et
continuer d'appeler régulièrement mon
correspondant qui à chacune de des
conversations que j'ai avec lui me tente
chaque jour davantage de venir voir sur
place ce qu'il en est parce qu il a
c'est un homme qui a sacrifié toute sa
vie toute sa vie pour pouvoir être un
éleveur et ça mérite effectivement que
l'état ne soit pas à côté mais soit
effectivement en soutien donc je réponds
déjà globalement à plusieurs d'entre
vous sur le sujet revenons à d'autres
sujets notamment ceux qui ont été
abordés conte qui concerne les
mécanismes de soutien aux énergies
renouvelables pour la capacité que nous
aurons atteindre les objectifs que nous
sommes fixés plusieurs l'ont dit de 23 %
à l'horizon de 2020 on va dire que sur
le solaire
nous avons déclenché un plan d'urgence
qui j'en suis sûr va donner ses fruits
je connais la difficulté de la filière
j'ai dit tout à l'heure les nombre
d'emplois qui ont été perdus des
entreprises en difficulté j'ai en tête
les salariés de l'usiné bosch de
vénissieux qui par exemple sont dans une
difficulté alors qu'ils ont une
technique tout à fait formidable mais
leur rentabilité et c'est là où ils ont
besoin de l'état serre que l'état fixe
un cadre réglementaire 1 bride rachat
qui donne de la lisibilité d'ailleurs
j'aurai pour une bière d'une façon à
cette question-là sûr que peut faire
l'état vis-à-vis des énergies
renouvelables il peut faire plusieurs
choses il doit lancer effectivement des
appels d'offres importants sur toutes
les énergies renouvelables elles sont
pas toutes à la même maturité mais
l'état doit être en soutien les appels
d'offres dans l'éolien les appels
d'offres dans l'hydrolien ça doit être
quelque chose de fondamental de il doit
le faire dans la simplification
beaucoup d'entre vous ont parlé de cette
nécessité de simplification gelé abordés
à l'occasion d'un exemple sur la
méthanisation mais je pourrais le faire
sur bien d'autres domaines
je tenais à vous le dire ça n'a rien de
considérable mais j'ai recruté à mon
cabinet une chargée de mission qui est
déléguée à la simplification du droit de
l'environnement
c'est à dire que je lui ai demandé
demandé expressément de regarder
ce code de l'environnement que nous
avons qui est une montagne qui est une
montagne d'ailleurs assez inefficace en
fait parce que il y a énormément de
recours et au plan pénal pratiquement
jamais de condamnation très très peu de
condamnations -dont qu'il est à la fois
tout fut compliqué et en même temps il
donne pas toute la satisfaction en
termes de protection donc j'ai dédié
quelqu'un sorte de cost killer qui va
non pas baisser la garde sur les
questions de protection pas droit pourra
pas compter sur moi pour baisser la
garde sur les questions de protection
mais faire en sorte que parfois par
empilement on est des mécanismes qui
fait qu'ils font que manière que le
président l'a vu quand il dit si un
impôt nouveau on en enlève un bain je
pense que si on a une norme nouvelle il
faut effectivement on enlevait une ou en
tout cas ont simplifié et donc sur le
solaire ce que nous envoie sur l'éolien
on a travaillé on travaillera encore sur
des simplifications l'histoire des cinq
membres reconnaissaient la législation
qui a permis d' d'adoucir tout cela et
on a lancé bien sûr des appels d'offres
éolien deuxième appel d'offres national
un troisième pourra être éventuellement
lancer sur les mécanismes de soutien
c'est un travail de long terme pour
avoir des dispositifs lisible au bon
rapport entre coûts et bénéfices et mes
services viennent de me proposer une
méthode de concertation avec les
différents acteurs qui nous permettra
ensuite de lancer ces appels d'offres de
manière plus plus plus favorable et pour
chaque filière je parlais de la maturité
de chaque filière il faudra bien sûr
adapté les soutiens notamment de la
recherche et développement à l'aide au
déploiement sur ces questions sur la
plus particulièrement la filière
industrielle solaire qui est en
difficulté ou plusieurs d'entre vous on
signalait la baisse des raccordements 1
je crois que d'avoir entendu cela là
encore le gouvernement à lancer
rapidement un nouveau dispositif tarifs
appel d'offres les candidatures à
l'appel d'offres grandes surfaces à
hauteur de 1500 mégawatts à louer montre
que le dispositif est suffisamment
attractif et c'est le cas aussi pour
les tarifs on devrait donc voir les
raccordements ré augmenter leur
viendrait forcément devant vous et on
verra ce qu'il en est mais on devrait
voir en 2014 dès le début 2014
des inscriptions nous avons des
inscriptions aux files d'attentes
l'inscription files d'attentes c'est pas
la certitude mais c'est un indicateur
qui lie à un engouement à nouveau sur
ces questions sur les concessions
hydroélectriques procéderont courteau
qui m'en a parlé j'ai bien entendu le
message et je sais à quoi il fait
référence il fait référence à un
courrier qu avec deux de mes collègues
que traditionnellement d'ailleurs on
oublie pour me faire porter à moi seul
sur les épaules la responsabilité de la
charge de cette décision
une réponse au premier président de la
cour des comptes nous avons
effectivement indiqué qu il nous
apparaissait en l'état des procédures et
notamment parce que la commission
européenne nous le demande de faire en
sorte que ce soit le système de
concurrence qui soit retenue mais pour
autant je le dis ici comme je les dis
d'ailleurs à l'assemblée nationale
devant la commission des affaires
économiques
ce courrier ne vaut pas la politique que
nous voulons mettre en oeuvre et nous
avons des dialogues notamment avec les
collectivités locales qui sont très
intéressés pour pouvoir être encore des
acteurs importants de ces conditions
hydrauliques et qui craignent que
l'ouverture à la concurrence et bien
faire face perdre à des opérateurs
français
la gestion de ces concessions et que
d'autres venus d'autres pays qui
effectivement je l' ai entendu n'ont pas
toujours la même réciprocité puisse
permettre en est alors la commission
européenne a ouvert une enquête sur les
concessions en france je le rappelle mi
septembre
c'est pas on n'est pas sans le regard
alors on pourra avoir un autre débat
sans fin sur notre indépendance notre
souveraineté et là là là le rôle de la
commission européenne a sont là moi je
vous parlerai du changement de statut
d'edf qui a été voté par une autre
majorité et qui nous rend aussi fragile
et en difficulté sur ces questions là
mais toujours est il que ce que nous
voulons c'est bien sûr répondre à la
pression européenne sur le sujet mais
aussi travailler
schéma qui favorise les électro
intensifs notamment sur le long terme
une question m'a été posée sur la
révision de la directive énergie la
commission européenne a présenté en
avril 2011 une proposition de révision
de la directive relative à la taxation
des produits énergétiques et de
l'électricité
si la nouvelle directive était adopté la
taxation de l'énergie reposerait sur
deux composantes une composante liée aux
émissions de co2 est une composante liée
à la consommation basée sur le contenu
énergétique c'est la question de savoir
vous vous faites une contribution climat
énergie mais que fait l'europe sur cette
question là la france soutient ce texte
dans une certaine mesure l'anticipent
avec la prise en compte d'une part
carbone dans notre fiscalité
cette négociation est difficile elle
requiert comme toujours en matière
fiscale
un accord à l'unanimité de ses membres
at elle toujours la règle particulière
sur la fiscalité
or certains pays s'opposent au texte
dans son état actuel je pense notamment
à l'allemagne au royaume uni et à la
pologne
alors nous pouvons déplorer l'absence
d'ambition qui caractérise le débat mais
nous restons moteur dans les discussions
et nous voulons convaincre
bien sûr le reste de nos partenaires la
question m'a été posée peut-être que je
l'apprends pas dans le bonheur mais j'y
viens tout de suite c'est quel est le
point de faiblesse sur les questions
d'énergie
c'est l'absence de politique énergétique
européenne qui fait cruellement défaut
lorsque je me déplace en europe je
rencontre les autres états membres
je mesure ce caractère hétéroclite de
notre politique européenne
chaque état gère de manière parfaitement
nationale l'allemagne peut décider
unilatéralement de sortir totalement du
nucléaire comme elle le fait et de
rouvrir des mines de charbon qui sur le
plan du bilan des gaz à effet de serre
n'est pas quelque chose qui est
formidable
la pologne que j'ai rencontrée elle elle
voit dans la possibilité d'extraire le
gaz de schiste de son sous-sol une
question d'indépendance de patriotisme
presque énergétique parce qu'elle a un
voisin la russie depuis
longtemps et que pendant longtemps elle
a extrait du charbon et que là pour
continuer d'avoir cette indépendance et
son patriotisme énergétique elle se dit
qu'elle a dans son sous-sol
effectivement des d énergie qu elle peut
utiliser donc cette notion de politique
européenne énergétique quelque chose de
fort vous avec le président de la
république a d'ailleurs été le premier à
proposer qu'on en débatte et le 20 mars
prochain un conseil européen sera
consacrée notamment à cette question de
la politique européenne énergétique est
absolument à 10 heures parce que
l'interdépendance des politiques
énergétiques on le voit bien
elle est considérable lorsqu'on est
obligé comme je le fait d'écrire à mes
partenaires allemands italiens pour
m'inquiéter un peu des réserves de
stockage de gaz pour avait des
difficultés que nous pourrions avoir cet
hiver d'approvisionnement parce que nous
sommes dans des mécanismes
interdépendants où nous nous aidons les
uns les autres montre assez que cette
politique européenne énergétique
elles nous montrent et elle manque et je
demande bien évidemment aux
parlementaires nationaux dans d'en être
les relais un mot sur les impacts de la
composante carbone sur les ménages
d'abord je voudrais aussi dire à ceux
qui m'ont posé la question de savoir si
la progression de la trajectoire du prix
de la tonne dans la composante carbone
qui aboutissait à 4 milliards en 2016
n'allez pas finalement être l' inverse
de ce qu on appelle la stabilisation des
prélèvements obligatoires
telle qu'elle a été annoncée devrait
dire vous même qu'il y à une taxe que
vous ne votez jamais vous au parlement
et qui impacte le pouvoir d'achat des
familles où la compétitivité des
entreprises c'est l'augmentation sans
fin des prix de l'énergie
le gaz a augmenté de 80 % entre 2000 et
2012 l'électricité a augmenté de 20 %
entre 2000 et 2012 ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que c'est beaucoup plus
neutre
on le voit pas ça se fait année après
année par petit pourcentage mais ce
qu'ils mangent le pouvoir d'achat des
français et notamment des plus modestes
ce qui réduit la compétitivité des
entreprises c'est cela
citer le chiffre tout à l'heure si nous
ne faisons rien nous ne faisons rien
nous laissons la trajectoire comme l 100
à 150 milliards d'euros de facture
énergétique en plus pour la france qui
va la payer les entreprises et les
ménages
voyez bien que cette idée d'un nouveau
mix énergétique d'une transition
énergétique
c'est pas une lubie c'est pas pour faire
plaisir à telle ou telle formation
politique c'est indispensable
indispensable y compris même dans une
relation j'allais dire d'économie
libérale et concurrentiel si nous
voulons que nos entreprises conservent
leur compétitivité si nous voulons que
les ménages ne soient pas asphyxier par
la précarité énergétique nous avons
l'obligation effectivement de travailler
sur ces questions pour dray un exemple
en vous donnant des exemples vous avez
un couple qui vit à paris qui se
chauffent au gaz qui a un véhicule
essence
ils dépensent sur l'année 2015 2015 42
euros de plus en gaz et 15 euros de plus
en essence en 2016 ces moments seront de
64 euros et 29 euros
on peut toujours considérer que c'est
beaucoup et que cette économie là il
serait mieux de la faire mais je
voudrais quand même ramené à chaque fois
ce que cela représente
c'est à dire que la progression de la
prix de la tonne dans la composante car
bande représente quelques centimes
d'euros par litre et pas des chiffres
absolument astronomiques
si vous prenez un autre couple qui vit
dans le milieu rural et qui vient de se
marier et qui s'installe dans le perche
pas pourquoi dans le perche mais il se
trouve que là ils s'installent dans le
perche dans une zone isolée il doit bien
y avoir des zones isolées dans le perche
ils ont une berline qui roule au gasoil
et une cuve de fioul ils pourraient
habiter dans le gers parce que landes
gers
les gens ont aussi dans des zones
isolées une ou deux voitures et une cuve
de fuel souvent qui a plus de 30 ans eh
bien ils paieront 49 euros de plus sur
le fuel en 2015 97 euros en 2016 30
euros de plus sur le carburant en 2015
et 60 euros
en 2016 et grâce à l'aide de l'état ils
pourront aussi consommer moins d'énergie
parce que l'objectif de la contribution
climat énergie 7 en fin de course faire
gagner du pouvoir d'achat aux ménages et
de la compétitivité
c'est les sortir de l'addiction aux
énergies fossiles qui se traduit par les
augmentations dont je vous devais parler
a pas quelque chose de punitif ce n'est
pas une fiscalité de rendement la
contribution climat énergie c'est une
fiscalité je le dis très doucement de
peur que éventuellement le souvenir de
michel charasse fasse que ma voix et
jusqu'au conseil constitutionnel le kite
conseil constitutionnel vous le savez a
horreur de la fiscalité comportementale
parce que lorsque une fiscalité
comportementale
c'est ce qu'il avait fait pour la taxe
carbone que l'opposition d'aujourd'hui
la majorité d'hier avait fait voter en
2009 et qu'il a pour le coup était une
taxe punitive additionnel et qui
prenaient du pouvoir d'achat aux ménages
mais j'imagine que vous l'avez
contestées à cette époque là est bien
celle là elle avait été elle avait on
regardera les minutes du journal
officiel mais elle avait été contestée
par le conseil constitutionnel parce que
justement elle était comportementale il
n'empêche que le souci que nous avons
c'est de sortir les ménages et les
entreprises de ses dépendances là et
c'est ce que nous ferons
voilà pour cette audition de philippe
martin le ministre de l'écologie qui est
notamment intervenu sur le projet de loi
de finances 2014
expliquant le fonctionnement de la
contribution climat énergie place tout
de suite à l'audition de jean jouzel le
célèbre climatologue français qui a été
auditionnée mercredi par la commission
du développement durable
le climatologue est notamment intervenu
sur le cinquième rapport du giec le
groupe intergouvernemental d'experts sur
le climat
un cas remis un rapport la semaine
dernière un rapport alarmant revenant
sur la multiplication des phénomènes
climatiques extrêmes l'augmentation des
températures ou encore la montée des
océans et qui a parlé dans ce rapport
d'un réchauffement climatique sans
équivoque
mais tout de suite retour donc à cette
audition qui a eu lieu mercredi au sénat